général on sait qu'on va pas au mur
jaune me marre de signaux donc là c'est
vrai cette pause llc à la saiso lit
parce que je trouve que ça fait une
jolie taille et ça fait déjà nuit comme
ça une jolie compte que j'aime bien tu
es créatrice de contenus sur des
plateformes où on peut vendre ces photos
c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça je vends mes
photos du coup sur owni fans maintenant
ça à faire depuis une grosse année en
fait c'est quand j'ai commencé à faire
des à poser
lingerie nu sûr
sur instagram et il y avait quelques
personnes qui aimaient ce que je faisais
du coup qu'ils me proposaient si j'avais
dû contenu à vendre du coup j'ai
commencé comme ça et je me sentais je me
sentais bien avec ça ça ne me sentais
pas dégradé donc je me suis dis bah on
peut se faire de l'argent grâce à grâce
à ce qu'on aime faire bat karé ment
est-ce que tu retouche des photos alors
oh non je retouche très très rarement
mes photos donc j'ai
je m'accepte avec gdg des boutons j'ai
des cicatrices j'ai des poils mais je
véhicule ce message de s'accepter comme
on est et s'accepter notre beauté en
tant que tel donc ma page jeu mais
plusieurs photos avec voilà une petite
description des choses que je fais avec
des cordes aussi il ya des photos des
vidéos qui peuvent fuite et ça ça c'est
possible même dans tout donc donc vous
quand même faire attention à ce qu'on
poste combien tu vends des photos alors
mon abonnement sûrement eu ni femmes ni
les
17 dollars dont pour un abonnement
le donc on est fan la plateforme prend
je crois de dollars dessus et du coup
par mois je me fais environ un mille
euros et ceux qui veulent du contenu
privé pour un peu adapté c'est plus cher
tu fais ce que j'ai payé de sa plus cher
oui c'est ça ouais je suis payé ça plus
cher mon prix de base c'est environ 40
euros
donc depuis une année en gros un an j'ai
gagné douze mille euros ils ont des
parents sont au courant que j'ai fait ça
alors
au tout début mes parents ont des pas au
courant donc quelqu'un les a mis au
courant sans que je sache
et du coup leur réaction était assez a
été perturbé et il se demandait pourquoi
je faisais ça ce que je comprends pas ce
que ben ils connaissent pas ils se
disent qu'elles archivant des photos
d'elle un poil sur les réseaux mais mais
en leur expliquant ils ont pour ce
qu'ils ont compris et puis maintenant je
suis majeur je sais ce que je fais je
suis en accord avec ça aujourd'hui est
ce que tu vis de ça tu vas un autre
métier à côté
alors non aujourd'hui je ne vis pas de
ça donc à côté j'ai
j'ai mon métier de barmaid quand même
qui est assez important parce que ça me
permet d'avoir un revenu fixe et je me
sens en sécurité avec un revenu fixe
parce que les fans jeu je pense pas
vouloir en faire mon métier
ce que je trouve que ça serait une
source très importante de stress de se
dire que son travail repose sur son
corps tu as quelqu'un dans ta vie en ce
moment où est en ce moment je vois
quelqu'un oui et cette personne est au
courant que deux ironie phan huy lê au
courant et enfin il n'y a pas de ya pas
de problème avec ça
et ici un problème avec ça
bah on en parlera mais mais en tout cas
c'est enfin je changerais pas parce que
je suis comme je suis et je changerai
pas pour pour la personne au club